A LOT OF TIME TELLING YOU HOW
THE CITIES ARE FALLING APART.
PRETTY AMAZING.
WE ARE NOT EXACTLY SURE WHY THIS
IS HAPPENING, BUT THE CITY OF
MIAMI IS ON TRACK FOR THE LOWEST
CRIME RATE SINCE THE 1930s.
THAT'S WHEN AL CAPONE WAS THERE.
WHY?
WE ARE HERE WITH THE MAYOR OF
MIAMI.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOU DOING IN
MIAMI THAT AMERICA --
>> I'M GOING TO BLOW YOUR MIND
AWAY.
WE INCREASED MONEY FOR POLICE.
WE HAVE ALSO LOWERED TAXES TO
THE LOWEST LEVEL IN RECORDED
HISTORY WHICH HAS BUMPED IT UP
TO THE SECOND -- IN RECORDED
HISTORY.
WE ARE THE HAPPIEST AND
HEALTHIEST CITY IN AMERICA, LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT PEOPLE ARE HAPPY,
HEALTHY, WORKING.
THAT'S BEEN THE MIAMI MIRACLE
STORY WHICH -- WASHINGTON
NIGHTMARE STORY THAT YOU HAVE
ARTICULATED TONIGHT AND OVER THE
LAST FEW WEEKS.
>> THERE IS THIS GREAT VIDEO
CIRCULATING AROUND THE INTERNET
OF THE RIOTS IN 2020.
ALL OF THESE COPS -- WE ARE NOT
DOING THAT HERE.
DID YOU EVER HAVE MEANINGFUL
RIOTS IN MIAMI?
>> WE DIDN'T.
WE DREW THE LINE IN THE SAND.
NOT GOING TO TOLERATE IT IN OUR
CITY.
THAT FIRST NIGHT, WE HAD SOME
ISSUES, BUT RIGHT AWAY, IT WAS
CLEAR THAT WE WEREN'T GOING TO
ACCEPT IT, AND WHOEVER CAME IN
OBVIOUSLY REALIZE THAT -- MIAMI
WOULD NOT ACCEPT THAT KIND OF
BEHAVIOR.
>> WHAT IS FUNNY IS THAT FOR A
LONG TIME, PROBABLY AFTER
1980 -- THAT TV SHOW FOR
"MIAMI VICE."
IS IT THAT DANGEROUS --
>> I WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
MIAMI.
300 PLUS HOMICIDES RIGHT NOW,
AND --
RIGHT NOW, WE ARE AT 28 TODAY,
SO 300 PLUS TO 28.
WE HAD TO LOOK BACK IN OUR
ARCHIVES TO SEE THE LAST TIME --
IT'S A TRUSTED AND TRUE FORMULA
FOR SUCCESS.
WE KEEP PEOPLE SAFE, AND HAVE
THIS INNOVATION FOR HIGH-PAYING
JOBS.
>> IT'S PRETTY INCREDIBLE.
MURDER IS THE ONE THING --